along with a special report homepage I'm
Bret Baier we had a discussion on the
panel tonight about president Trump's
cancellation of next month's scheduled
summit with North Korean leader Kim
jong-un and the breaking news of the
North Koreans responding you can see the
segment right here on the website along
with reports by John Roberts and Greg
Powell count in Seoul also on the
homepage my interview with Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell Friday
the latest on North Korea and our
whatever happened to segment focuses on
Natalie Holloway will see at 6 p.m.
Eastern on Fox News Channel four special
report